ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
heute sehen sie mich nur allein hier und
nicht ein hausmann heraus man wird den
rest des semesters nicht regelmäßig mehr
teilnehmen können aber er hausmann war
ja auch wie wir am anfang gesagt hatten
der experte für die modernen theorien
und ich wenn überhaupt dann für die
älteren theorien und heute also
aristoteles ist natürlich ein ältere
position vielleicht die älteste mit der
wir hier anfangen können und da habe ich
mich jetzt ihr bereit erklärt diese
position zu behandeln und ich habe auch
gesagt ich muss heute etwas früher los
weil ich einen flug bekommen muss und da
muss man immer zeit ihren flughafen
seien aber denk ich denke wir werden
heute einiges über aristoteles sagen
können zuletzt zur letzten sitzung
hatten sie noch fragen zur letzten
sitzung mit robert kahn das war ja noch
dieser debatte pianist
haben sie dazu noch fragen was es mit
diesem liberta realismus auf sich hat
ist ihnen die position klar wenn sie die
mal ganz kurz beschreiben sollte von
robert kennedy würden sie das tun
[Musik]
oder warum anders welche der bisherigen
position fanden sie am intuitivsten an
einleuchten wir hatten jetzt hier also
begonnen mit harry frankfurt das war
einer der hat grob gesagt dass man nur
seinen ersten aufsatz betrachtet hatte
gesagt also willensfreiheit besteht
darin eben alle volition zweiter stufe
auszuprägen und alternative
möglichkeiten sind nicht notwendig um
willens frei zu sein
das ist die position eins ich schreibe
mir ein bisschen zusammenfassend weil
wir jetzt den neueren teil sagen hinter
uns lassen und sagen wir dass die erste
position händler verfährt und der sagt
praktisch also was gehört bei dem der
koalition in zwei stufen
stufe und seit die negation von php das
ist jetzt die erste position die wir
hatten
man kann natürlich noch viele andere
punkte dazu schreiben aber ich möchte
jetzt einfach nur mal ganz grob eben
darstellen dann haben wir die zweite
position
das war der peter dran im regen was
würden sie jemandem erzählen einer
kommilitonin einem kommilitonen der von
dem noch nie was gehört hat wie würden
sie seine position bezeichnen
wir hatten da im seminar so ein label
uns überlegt wissen sie noch auf diesen
methoden auf diesen positionen papier
wie wir ihn da bezeichnet hatten
das sagt noch mal wieder von innen wegen
über freiheit freiheit ist ein
ja genau also müsst ihr realismus also
vielleicht bei harry frankfurt kümmern
auch noch mal schreibe kompatibel ist
man sagt man tschüs sagen zur harry
frankfurt es sei ein semi kompatibel ist
und zwar semi deswegen sehe man ja immer
nur halb so ein halber weiler
alternative möglichkeiten nicht für
wichtig erachtet für willensfreiheit
also nun also nicht der fall dass das
prinzip alternative möglichkeiten gilt
und deswegen weil er aber dennoch sagt
dass eben freiheit mit kompatible muss
freiheit mit determinismus kompatibel
ist
obwohl er dieses prinzip bestreiten in
denen auch manche einen semi kompatibel
ist
jetzt haben sie bei der nächsten
position peter fangen wegen gesagt
mysteriös ist dann sagen wir mysterien
ismus
und könnte man seine position noch
bezeichnet wenn jetzt harry frankfurt 1
kompatibel ist ist was ist dann wieder
von ihnen wagen für eine position was
sagte über freiheit und determinismus
sind die kompatibel ja tendenziell
inkompatibel ist also seine position ist
eigentlich folgende er sagt freiheit und
determinismus oder genauer gesagt
willensfreiheit und determinismus
schließen sich aus deswegen dieser
inkompatibel ist aber er sagt sowohl
freiheit als auch determinismus sind war
das ist also dieses paradoxe er sagt
freiheit und determinismus schließen
sich eigentlich aus als inkompatibel ist
aber der determinismus ist war und wir
sind auch frei und daraus folgt dann
diese position des mysteriums muss
deswegen ist freiheit ein mysterium
freiheit ist nach seiner thesen nicht
kompatibel mit der wahrheit des
determinismus aber wir haben sie dennoch
wir sind frei wir müssen sie
voraussetzen aus ganz verschiedenen
gründen aus gründen der moralischen
zurechenbarkeit schuldzuweisung und so
weit wir kommen gar nicht damit sagen
aus auf diesen begriff zu verzichten wir
brauchen freiheit willen zweiten starken
aber wir können es nicht mit dem
determinismus kompatibel denken und der
determinismus es aber war das ist
konsequenz argument kann ich auch noch
mal hin stand also folgt so eine art ja
so eine art wo verwunderung haltung st
hier haben wir jetzt noch konsequenz
kann von ihnen jemand mal sagen was es
mit dem konsequenz argument auf sich hat
wie sind sie noch was das konsequenz
argument besagt wir hatten in der
letzten sitzung sonne so eine formel 1
geschrieben sondern eine gleichung und
so nimmt und logisches logische
formalisierung wissen sie noch wie die
war konsequenz argument also das besagt
wir haben 0 0 ist ein zustand der
vergangenheit ein beliebiger zustand von
sachverhalten in der vergangenheit oder
meinetwegen auch jetzt ein beliebiger
zustand des universums und wir
konjugieren ihn also wir setzen dazu
noch intel seit die summe aller
naturgesetze aller determinieren
faktoren als in l kommt der
determinismus ins spiel
elvis oder lex und daraus folgt dann
müssen klammer umsetzen
daraus folgt dann sein okay okay ist
dann jeder beliebige spätere meinetwegen
zustand und das ist das konsequenz
argument ein bisschen ja also wenn wir
einen bestimmten zustand der welt haben
und wenn alle gesetze bekannt sind oder
eben nur vollständig sind und wir sie
ansetzen können dann folgt daraus eben
das für jeden zukünftigen fall eben
alles detailliert ist nach diesen
gesetzen und so können sie das auch gut
vorstellen
letztendlich auch sind ihre handlungen
oder was auch immer sie vollziehe neben
detailliert durch faktoren die vor ihrer
geburt lagen und deswegen können sie
diese sache nicht in der hand haben also
dinge die sie noch nicht geboren waren
können sie natürlich keine verantwortung
übernehmen aber dass konsequenz argument
sagt einfach das sei jetzt die jetzige
zustand aber der wird eben durch
faktoren determiniert die vor ihrer
geburt lagen die gesetze galten schon
vor ihrer geburt
und p 0 ist ein zustand von
sachverhalten die vor ihrer geburt schon
gehalten
konsequenz argument und jetzt müssen wir
noch hier zum schluss damit sie mal die
drei wichtigsten positionen haben
jetzt haben wir hier noch den robert k
was fällt ihnen zudem noch mal eins dem
robert k haben sie dann alle ideen wenn
sie jetzt mal hier schauen wir haben
jetzt hier ein kompatibel ist wir haben
ein eben kompatibel ist und was brauchen
wir jetzt hier noch um die
vollständigkeit zu haben und leben sie
noch nie hatten wir diese position
klassifiziert als was hatten wir sie
betitelt
das war so ein ganz komischer begriff
der auch verwechselt wird häufig mit
position in der politischen philosophie
erinnern sie sich noch
alles war ein libertarian oder ein
libertarian is muss also ich habe eine
harley barrios muss
liberta realismus bedeutet noch mal das
leben wir frei sind
und das weil wir frei sind eben der
determinismus falsch ist
also wir sind deswegen willens frei weil
determinismus so nicht gilt als er würde
beschreibt er würde das einfach
bestreiten hier würde das beschreibung
vor allem er würde wahrscheinlich das
bestreiten hier dass das eben die
naturgesetze und so vollständig
determinieren es gibt ja auch ganz viele
einfallstore wenn man so einen
determinismus bestreiten möchte zum
beispiel können sie ansetzen an dem
begriff des natur gesetzes der gesetze
die sind nämlich gar nicht so klar
inwiefern naturgesetze und der termin
ist gar nicht so klar
das sagt man immer so da gibt es die
naturgesetze und die terminieren uns
aber wie dieses genau machen oder ob sie
es überhaupt genau machen bisschen jedes
detail das ist überhaupt nicht klar also
dass da kann man zb ansetzen ja und also
die batterie an ismus heißt wir sind
frei arbeitete determinismus ist falsch
und deswegen habe ich in der letzten
sitzung den vorschlag gebracht kommen
sie ruhig ein habe ich den vorschlag
gebracht dass wir den die position des
liberalismus als eine art von kompatibel
ist muss bezahlen könnten aber eine
kompatible muss von freiheit nicht mit
determinismus sondern von freiheit und
in determinismus war es gibt ja immer
diese zwei probleme also freiheit
wir haben hier erstens den determinismus
und zwei uns in determinismus
muss manche sagen auch zufall aber das
würde ich nochmal hier als dritten punkt
unterscheiden und die frage ist wie
verhält sich freiheit ob sie diesen drei
positionen
es ist klar dass freiheit natürlich mit
zufall nicht kompatibel ist es ist klar
zufall wenn sie da eine münze werfen und
sagen das ist freiheit das ist irgendwie
begrifflich widersprüchen determinismus
wird schwierig auch da werden viele
sagen also prima fazit wenn sie mal eine
umfrage machen würden die meisten sagen
er behaupte ich jetzt mal müsste man
eine straßenumfrage machen wäre
soziologisches experiment auch
experimentelle philosophie würden die
meisten sagen freiheit hat hier mehr zu
tun mit in der termin ismus behaupte ich
jetzt mal die meisten würden sagen frei
ist ich bin ich gezwungen bin nicht
determiniert nicht terminiert zufall ist
freiheit nicht aber in der termin ist
der termin ist muss und vertrag weil die
meisten würden behaupte ich jetzt mal
diese these vertreten freiheit sei in
der termin ist mit in der termin ist
muss verbunden aufs wesentliche und
diese position vertritt auch robert
caine als er vertritt sie seien
kompatibel ist muss von freiheit und in
der termin ist muss er häufig wird das
aber nicht als kompatibel ismus
bezeichnet sind kompatibel ist ische
position werden immer positionen genannt
designfreiheit und determinismus ist
kompatibel und deswegen nennt man die
libertarian essen muss
und jetzt gibt es eben verschiedene
positionen des liberalismus es gibt zum
beispiel solche auffassung die sagen wir
haben da ein vermögen 1 1 endergebnis
vermögen und das steht außerhalb von
raum und zeit das ist gar nicht der
natur gesetz unterworfen
und da sagt jetzt robert kennedy sei ein
extra faktor also er kommt so zufällig
wie so kommt einfach aus dem nichts
kommt er so eine ursache von uns die gar
nichts mit den naturgesetzen zu tun
sowas ist natürlich problematisch weil
sowas dann wie so ein wunder erscheint
und da ist dann dieser weg zum zufall
auch nicht mehr weit
deswegen sagt robert keller müssen das
ganz anders denken
wir müssen sagen
also es ist in determiniert aber dennoch
pro babbel ist ish und kausal
determiniert also eher wird es sagen
sind dennoch usa kausal verursacht also
das man geben
nach bob kane sagen kann unser wille ist
gespalten und zwar vollständig gespalten
in zwei motive er bringt dieses beispiel
der business women also eine
geschäftsfrau die alt auf einen termin
muss ganz zügig hin so wie ich jetzt
gleich zur flughafen und die sich dann
aber auf dem weg einen verbundenen
menschen eine verwundete person
und sie weiß genau wenn ich jetzt mich
um die verwundete person oder verletzte
person kümmere ich dann verpasse ich das
meeting und dann werde ich berufliche
große einschränkungen haben dann bekomme
ich nicht meinen job oder was ist
irgendwas ganz wichtig ist und sie will
aber auch zugleich diesen dieser person
helfen
sie ist also irgendwie in sich zerrissen
das ist das thema der willens spaltung
klassisches thema da kommen wir auch
noch in der nächsten sitzung bei
augustinus drauf wir haben jetzt erst
noch mal aristoteles und sagt diese
willen spaltung ist gar nicht schlimm
sondern wir können sagen dass wie auch
immer jetzt die entscheidung ausgeht am
ende ob jetzt diese geschäfts vor sich
für diesen diese personen die da liegt
kümmert um die kümmert oder ob sie zum
mädchen geht sie kann sich mit beiden
optionen identifizieren so das wort
schon ausgang er das gar nicht
problematisch ist dann hatten wir aber
mark und ich uns und auch sie sich
überlegt aber wie kommt dann jetzt ob
jetzt die eine oder die andere option
den
vorzug bekommt muss da nicht noch ein
kleiner schalter umgelegt werden und da
hat jetzt eben dann ganz viel dazu
geschrieben er spricht der mannschaft
von zu einem physiologischen vorgang der
vielleicht gar nicht mehr so bewusst ist
dann kann man sich aber natürlich fragen
wo liegt da noch die kontrolle
er hat es auch mit einem value
experiment beschrieben ich habe das in
der zusammenfassung bisschen
ausführlicher noch dargestellt also
jedenfalls oder matt cain ist einer der
eine libysche position bis jetzt und
jetzt will ich sie fragen zum abschluss
dieses systematischen teils welche
position halten sie für am
überzeugendsten jeder finden hat jetzt
eine stimme also bitte melden sie sich
notiere mir jetzt die anzahl wer ist für
harry frankfurt wie die ganz deutlich
123456 wer ist für peter von 12.45 und
wer ist für robert k 1234
ja da haben wir doch hier in klaren
sieger nämlich ganz schön der reihe nach
also 654 frankfurt hat gewonnen
ich glaube auch tatsächlich dass sie in
so fern dass ich will jetzt hier auch
gar nicht groß partei ergreifen aber
harry frankfurt position lässt sich in
meinen augen am besten an die fluss
tradition anschließen also zb
augoustinos auch den wir in der nächsten
sitzung noch zu sprechen kommen das war
aber nicht so nicht bedeuten dass die
nicht auch problematisch ist aber die
lässt sich so ein bisschen am
leichtesten händel und sagt ihr zu
machen
diesen bisschen die angenehmste also
meine präferenz ist sie auch aber wie
gesagt so und damit haben wir jetzt den
systematischen teil abgeschlossen ist
sei denn sie haben noch eine frage haben
sie noch eine frage seit diesen drei
positionen
na ja also wir haben es versucht ihnen
die vor und nachteile so ein bisschen
darzustellen sie haben die wichtigsten
texte bekommen und dann gehen wir jetzt
hier auf diesen netten herrn hierüber
auf aristoteles und zwar auf seine
komische ethik und auf das dritte buch
vom handeln aus wollen holt vorsatz die
frage ist jetzt ob aristoteles überhaupt
schon so modernen freiheitsbegriff hat
ist eine schwierige frage hat auch noch
keinen richtigen willens begriff sagen
viele viele sagen dieser moderne willens
begriff auch mit dem modernen individuum
und sein der willensfreiheit der ist
erst seit augustinus prominent geworden
augustinus wird von hannah arendt als
erfinder oder auch entdecker des
modernen willens begriffs bezeichnet wir
wollen einfach mal schauen was ich bei
ihm schon hier so findet wir wollen
jetzt hier ein paar fragen stellen also
was versteht aristoteles unter
freiwilligkeit und wie verhalten sich
freiwilligkeit und determination nach
aristoteles zueinander
natürlich kann man sich jetzt noch
fragen wie es sich mit dem zwang verhält
zwang bringt alles total ist auch ins
spiel und das ist klar dass zwang für
ihn nicht vereinbar ist mit
freiwilligkeit
gut dann gehen wir weiter als wir lesen
jetzt hier über das gewollte und über
die bedingung der abwesenheit von zwang
und jetzt können wir einfach mal lesen
ich lese einfach mal vor da sind jetzt
immer auch in klammern sind jetzt
kritische begriffe die auch ein bisschen
erklären möchte also er sagt da nun die
charakterliche trugen die artez mit
effekten und handlungen zu tun hat und
da dasjenige was aus dem eigenen wollen
hervorgeht fuß lob und tat erfährt
wohingegen das was wohl gewollt akkus
ist verzeihung manchmal sogar mitleid
erregt müssen wohl diejenige die die
tugend untersuchen das gewollte und das
ungewollte gegen
abgrenzen das ist auch für die
gesetzgeber nützlich was die festsetzung
von ehrungen und strafen angeht also das
ist ganz zentral hier
wir können nur dann loben oder ihren und
strafen wenn wir eben voraussetzen dass
eine person in ihrem handeln will
endlich agiert hat und nicht ungewollt
agiert hat wenn es überhaupt gibt und
auch nicht unter zwang stand es gibt
natürlich bei aristoteles noch so ein
fall der mit freiheit nur schwer
verträgliche sind er zumindest
problematisch
es ist die ak si das ist die
willensschwäche da steckt das ist privat
iwe alpha dh dieses wien im deutschen
oder nicht
und gracia ist die herrschaft sie kennen
aristokratie
das ist die herrschaft der best artist
quartier das als eine nicht herrschaft
eine willensschwäche da sind wir nicht
mehr herr unseres willens
das ist auch so ein problem da kommt
dabei einer anderen stelle drauf aber
das sind alles faktoren die wir mit
einbeziehen müssen als wir müssen aus
eigenem willen und das nennt er hätte
sie es müssen wir handeln das ist
eigentlich ziemlich klar das ist die
bedingung dafür dass wir zurechenbar
sind sagte weiter als ungewollt gilt
üblicherweise das was durch zwang oder
aufgrund von unwissenheit neuer
geschieht gezwungen ist ein verhalten
dessen bewegung sache die arche
außerhalb liegt das heißt so beschaffen
ist dass der handelnde oder erleiden die
gar nichts beiträgt etwa wenn jemand
denn der wind irgendwohin trick oder
menschen die ein in ihrer gewalt haben
also das ist jetzt er es versteht jetzt
determinismus hier sehr lebensweltlich
konkret als zwar nicht in der gewalt ist
also zum beispiel könnte man das jetzt
auch mit diesen konsequenz argument in
verbindung bringen das sagt das was
außerhalb der hier als außerhalb des
dass der freiwilligkeit und außerhalb
ist natürlich auch so was
sagt hier dieses dieses l diese gesetze
die naturgesetze liegen auch außerhalb
von uns könnte man so ein bisschen damit
verbindung bringen
genau da ist noch ein weiterer
interessanter faktor dass sie auch noch
auf unwissenheit eingeht jetzt frage ich
aber mal zurück an sie glauben sie
wirklich dass unwissenheit ein grund ist
jemanden zum beispiel nicht zu schade
wenn er aufgrund von unwissenheit eine
person war es böses oder unmoralisches
getan hat was könnte man denn dann sagen
immer noch ja genau
genau es gibt zb fahrlässigkeit es so
also da müsste man fragen wofür ist
worin besteht der grund der unwissenheit
konnte die person ist überhaupt wissen
oder konnte sie jetzt gar nicht wissen
da da muss man ein bisschen noch
nachschauen also eben also unwissenheit
ist ambivalent es gibt sogar es gibt den
fall dass jemand aus fahrlässigkeit oder
aus leichtsinn aus leichtsinn dass
jemand sich einfach nicht an regeln hält
also dem sind die regel egal
dieser passung das ist möglich oder man
kümmert sich nicht darum an ist zu
unkonzentriert mann passt nicht auf aber
in bestimmten situationen muss man
irgendwie aufpassen
oder es gibt noch diesen fall dass
jemand sich selbst belügt dass man also
nun wissen deswegen ist weil man sich
was vormacht und dann an seine eigenen
fehler glaubt es gibt auch noch selbst
täuschen rationales selbsttäuschung dass
ein interessantes phänomen
[Musik]
wo dinge aus furcht vor größeren übel
oder im hinblick auf etwas wert haft es
kann getan werden
nehmen wir zum beispiel an ein tyrann
würde jemanden befehlen etwas niedriges
rollen zu tun
während er dessen eltern und kinder in
seiner gewalt hat und diese würden
gerettet wenn er die handlung ausführt
andernfalls aber müssten sie sterben
kann man im zweifel sein ob sie
ungewollt akkus oder gewollt hätte sie
es sind ähnliches die lage wo im sturm
güter über bord geworfen werden denn
ohne weiteres hilft niemand aus eignen
wollen ein guter weg wo dies aber die
bedingungen dafür ist sich selbst um und
übrigen zu retten tut es jeder der bei
verstand ist solche handlungen sind also
gemischt gleichen aber mehr gewollten
denn man wählt sie aus der handlungs
situation und das ziel einer handlung
richtet sich nach der situation kairos
was fällt ihnen dazu ein
ja
ach so ja okay also
wie handel was ist es jetzt mit diesem
auf sich dass man dinge über bord
schmeiß weg wie verstehen sie das jetzt
hier ja genau
man ist irgendwie der terminiert die
umstände sind ungünstig aber man hat da
noch sein gewissen spielraum und wie sie
richtig sagen das geringere übel kann
man dann immer noch will aber ansicht
würden jemand güter über bord schmeißen
würde niemand machen aber wenn es eben
einen anderen zweck dient dann kann man
so eine instrumentelle erwägungen
treffen uns zum telefon und sagte weiter
also muss man von gewollt oder ungewollt
im hinblick auf den zeitpunkt der
handlung sprechen dann handelt man in
den beschriebenen fällen wollen
in der tat liegt der ursprung der
bewegung der körperteile bei solchen
handlungen im handelnden selbst
behandlungen aber deren ursprung in ihm
selbst liegt gibt es auch bei ihm ob
autor sie zu tun oder nicht tun solche
handlungen sind also gewollt ohne
weiteres aber vielleicht ungewollt denn
niemand würde eine handlung dieser
beschriebenen art ohne weiteres wählen
also zeitpunkt sagt er hier zeitpunkt
der handlung man könnte vielleicht auch
noch sagen der umstand der handlung
dieselbe handlung dass jemand einfach so
dinge wertgegenstände oder güter über
bord wirft wird in einer bestimmten
situation plausibel national
verständlich in einer anderen situation
nicht wenn sie jetzt kein sturm gibt
warum sollte jemand dann was über bord
schmeißen
das ist also der zeitpunkt so verstehe
ich dass einer der umstand einer
handlung
wichtig ist hier dass der grund im
handelnden selbst liegen muss also das
ist die arche dieses prinzip jetzt kann
man sich natürlich fragen wie bringt man
das mit der modernen freiheits theorie
zusammen
also man könnte jetzt sagen das ist so
eine form von akteurs kausalität und
schreibe das ist der urgrund also
anfangen oder grund grund grund jetzt
erst so dieses basis aber anfang ist
vielleicht besser oder auch ursprung
vielleicht ursprung ist auch nicht
schlecht
und da könnte man sagen das ist
vielleicht so etwas wie akteurs
da geht jetzt etwas aus diesem akteure
hervor der grund der handlung liegt in
ihm selbst
also wir müssen uns einfach die frage
die wir uns heute und stellen wollen ist
die ist aristoteles wenn man überhaupt
so verstehen kann ist er ein kompatibel
ist
oder ist er ein inkompatibel ist das ist
jetzt die frage
oder ist das sogar eben als inkompatibel
ist ist er dann lieber tahrir- das war
die frage des todes
aber ich sehe also mir mir scheint
dieses gerede von archive in diesem
grund auf so was wie akteurs kausalität
zu weisen
aber ich weiß vielleicht haben sie noch
andere meinung dazu
weiter für solche handlung wird man
manchmal sogar gelobt und zwar dann wenn
man etwas niedriges oder unangenehmes
als preis für große und edle dinge
erträgt im entgegengesetzten fall wird
man getadelt denn das niedrige als preis
etwas zu tragen dass gar nicht nur mäßig
edel ist ist das merkmal eines
schlechten menschen manchen fällen
erfährt man kein lob aber doch
verzeihung in fällen in denen jemand
dinge die man nicht tun sollen aufgrund
von bedingungen tut die die menschliche
natur übersteigen und die keiner
aushalten würde
zu einigen handlung aber darf man sich
vielleicht nicht zwingen lassen sondern
sollte vielmehr nachdem man das
schlimmste erlitten hat den tod auf sich
nehmen denn die dinge die zum beispiel
den altmaier und des repeaters gezwungen
haben seine mutter zu töten erscheint in
der tat lächerlich es ist allerdings
manchmal schwierig zu beurteilen was man
um welche dinge willen wählen und was
man was um welche dinge will ertragen
muss und noch schwieriger ist es an
unseren urteilen festzuhalten
denn meistens ist das was man erwartet
unangenehm und das wozu man gezwungen
wird niedrig so das lob oder tadel
danach verteilt werden ob man dem zwang
erlegen oder ihm nicht erleben ist also
sagt er tadelte hängt damit zu tun hat
einen damit zusammen dass man einem
zwang erlegen ist
ja aber wenn man dem zwang er liegt ist
man dann nicht vielmehr unfrei und
verdient gar kein tadel
wie sehen sie das sie stellt er sich
jetzt dass er unterliegen einem eines
zwangs vor
[Musik]
also hier
erlegen oder nicht erlegen ist das
scheint ja vorauszusetzen dass man
selbst noch getadelt werden kann wenn
man dem zwang unterliegt
am 20
ja dass man nicht stark genug war würde
ich sagen also dass man nicht nicht
stark genug war dem zwang zu widerstehen
sage ich mal
vielleicht auch der versuchung so würde
ich es verstehen dass man also nicht
herr seiner selbst fahren so dass man so
ein bisschen willensschwach war diese
acacia hier
das acacia willensschwäche die frage ist
ob die zurechenbar ist dass sie sehen
das führt dann schon zu seinem charakter
lehre von so einer kugel lehre also
derjenige der eben letztendlich
moralisch handeln oder eben zwingen
nicht widerstehen kann der hat einen
charakter der der moralisch
problematisch ist der ist nicht
charakterfest bares läuft ja alles dann
auf diesen charakter hinaus diese diese
tugendhaften charakter welche arten von
verhalten sondern als erzwungenen etwa
allgemein die bei denen die ursache
außerhalb liegt oder der handelnde
nichts beiträgt was dagegen versicht
genommen hat auto ungewollt ist was aber
jetzt und um diese dinge willen gewählt
wird und dabei den bewegt ursprung im
handeln hat das ist zwar für sich
genommen ungewollt jetzt aber und um
diese dinge willen gewollt es entspricht
daher ihr gewollten handlungen den
handlungen betreffen immer dass einzelne
und dies ist gewollt welche dinge um
welche anderen dinge willen zu wählen
sind ist nicht leicht anzugeben da es
viele unterschiede in den einzelfällen
gibt
[Musik]
hier unterscheidet er jetzt hier
unterscheidet hier zwei formen von
erzwungen
hmm
[Musik]
die sich hieraus dass nur eine ursache
genau da ist da scheint jetzt eine art
von kompatibel ist muss sogar irgendwie
drin sein müssen genau schauen als
erster ist etwa allgemein die erste satz
zweiter satz bei denen fährst bei denen
die ursache außerhalb liegt und der
handelnde nichts beiträgt
das wäre jetzt das konsequenz argument
ein bisschen also das wäre jetzt so
etwas nur einfach die naturgesetze uns
nicht oder die gründe die uns den termin
nicht zur verfügung stehen
das ist ziemlich klar und jetzt kommt
aber der zweite fall der ist interessant
wer sagt was dagegen für sich genommen
um ungewollt ist was aber jetzt sind um
diese dinge willen gewählt wird und
dabei den bewegungen handelnden hat das
ist zwar für sich genommen ungewollt
jetzt aber und um diese dinge willen
gewollt wie verstehen sie das
[Musik]
genau
genau also dass da könnte man jetzt
sagen dass das jetzt so eine art von ist
ganz schwach sind von kompatibel ist
muss vielleicht ist da haben wir jetzt
faktoren von außen die uns determinieren
und wir müssen jetzt auf diese faktoren
irgendwie eingehen als wir müssen uns
jetzt diesen faktoren anpassen
gewissermaßen und sagen das geringere
übel wäre das war so was sie gemeint
hatten also da ist eigentlich das meint
damit an sich also für sich genommen hat
haut für sich genommen würde niemand
freiwillig güter die die güter sind im
begriff des guten steckt schon drin dass
man es will ja an sich würde niemand
güter wertgegenstände wegschmeißen
ansicht das ist einfach im begriff das
gut enthalten aber jetzt kann eben ein
eine situation kommen die ich nicht in
der hand habe wo ich eben diese handlung
vollziehen muss als mittel zum zweck ein
höheres gut zu erlangen zum beispiel
mein leben zu retten wenn ich eben das
schiff dadurch meine frühe feld wieder
machen und das wäre jetzt alles so eine
art mittelding wo es eigentlich
ungewollt ist aber eben durch diese
vernunft erwägung vielleicht die front
es ist sowas wie klugheit dass man
abwägt wenn ich das tue dann habe ich
das dann habe ich das dass es dann eben
doch wieder frei wird da ich eben mit
diesen situationen anpassen
wenn aber jemand sagen würde dass das
angenehme das ist das hätte und zwar das
wert hafte kalon und zwingen indem sie
als äußere bedingungen zwang ausüben
dann wäre für ihn alles erzwungen
denn diesen beiden dingen zu lieben tun
alle menschen alles was sie tun und
diejenigen die aufgrund von zwang und
widerwillig handeln handel mit lust
diejenigen aber die aufgrund des
angenehm und wert haften handeln an mit
uns und die die aufgrund des
erwirtschaften und angenehm handeln
handel mit lust außerdem ist es
lächerlich die äußeren bedingungen und
nicht sich selbst dafür verantwortlich
zu machen dass man sich von solchen
dingen zu leicht einfangen lässt und
lächerlich ist es auch die wehrhaften
handlung sich selbst zuzuschreiben die
niedrigen aber dem angenehm was aus
zwang geschieht scheint also dass zu
sein dessen ursprung außerhalb liegt und
dass die gezwungene person etwas
beiträgt
[Musik]
was ist jetzt hier das problem noch zum
schluss diese heute etwas kürzeren
sitzungen
was ist jetzt hier das problem
us-pass überlegte sich jetzt als gibt es
hier offensichtlich zwei arten von zwang
ja genau
genau also dass also gute gründe so zu
sagen gute gründe die zwingen uns nicht
oder sie bestimmen uns schon aber sie
bestimmen uns auf so eine weise dass die
art der bestimmtheit nicht mit
unfreiheit einhergeht das problem ist
folgendes er fragt sich jetzt das ist
nicht unser handeln immer schon bestimmt
durch das was angenehm ist mit tun doch
nur deswegen etwas weil es angenehm ist
ist dann das angenehm ist sagen das
wenige was uns unfrei macht das würden
sagen könnte man auch sagen oder
wir sind der terminiert durch das
angenehme wir können gar nicht anders
als das angenehme zu wollen
also sind wir und frei das würden sie
darauf sagen
die
das ist
genau man könnte also sagen ohne dass
gute würden wir gar nichts tun
also wir wären dann gerade dann doch
nicht unfrei also das gute das was uns
als angenehm erscheint ist überhaupt das
wenige was uns in bewegung setzt
als uns aktiviert und diese form von
aktivierung darf jetzt nicht mit zwang
verwechselt werden sondern zwang ist
gerade die deaktivierung könnte man
sagen also zwang ist gerade das
einfrieren und dieses angenehme gibt uns
motive das motiviert uns setzen die
bewegung und zwar eben in freiheit weil
natürlich jeder andere dinge als gut
ansehen kann
was für den einen gut ist es für die
anderen nicht gut das heißt da kommt
dann dieser spielraum plötzlich ins bild
dass also noch wichtig also immer könnte
schon sagen nach alles tun es ist alles
der terminiert durchaus bestimmt durch
das angenehme durch das was uns als gut
erscheint durchaus gute mache mir noch
ein zitat
dagegen dass sie wollen das ist was
durch zwang aufgrund von unwissenheit
geschieht dürfte das gewollt da sie
nicht gelten dessen ursprung im
handelnden selbst liegt wobei er die
einzelnen bedingungen kennt unter denen
die handlung stattfindet also hier ist
noch wichtig dass auch noch ein wissen
vorhanden sein muss von den bedingungen
[Musik]
schauen wir noch mal dieses zitat zum
schluss ferner worin unterscheiden sich
fehler aufgrund von überlegung und
fehler aufgrund von erregung im hinblick
auf die frage ob die handlung dem
eigenen wollen entgegen war
beide fehler sind zu meiden doch die
unvernünftigen effekte gelten
üblicherweise als eben zum menschlich so
dass auch diejenigen handlung zum
menschen gehören die aus erregung und
begierde hervorgehen
es wäre also seltsam sie zudem zu
rechnen was gegen das eigene wollen ist
allerdings gibt es hier eben noch zwei
fehler die uns über zu handeln
beschränken nämlich es gibt ein fehler
aufgrund von überlegung lobbyismus und
es gibt den fehler aufgrund von erregung
können sie dazu noch mal kurz was sagen
weil wie würden sie den fehler aufgrund
von überlegungen festmachen wie könnte
ein fehler geschehen
ein fehler aufgrund von überlegung
dass man zb ein denkfehler begegnen dass
man einfach sich verkalkuliert
das ist ein denkfehler und dann gibt's
natürlich auch den denkfehler aufgrund
von erregung wo man einfach nicht in der
lage ist sich zu konzentrieren
aufgrund von charakterlichen defiziten
sagte zwar oder auch von einflüssen die
unsere unsere dinge vermögen in ein
beeinträchtigt natürlich kann man sich
jetzt fragen inwiefern beide miteinander
zusammenhängen also ob nicht auch der
der feder der überlegung also was ihren
kognitiven sich vollzieht am ende
zurückzuführen ist auf eine form von
psychischer disposition nämlich die
erregung ist der denkfehler kam von
diesem psychischen zustand
das ist natürlich die spannende frage